what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about hasta z-- uniq anti magic
power including a mysterious aspect of
his power that has been largely
overlooked in many of the discussions
that I've been seeing so far there are
some things that we know about
hasta Santa magic and there are some
things that still remain a mystery and
in this video I will examine all the
info that we have so far about Austin's
anti magic in order to try and solve
some of the mysteries still surrounding
his 5-leaf grimoire and the demon who
dwells inside if you enjoy the black
clover content on this channel you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell you can check us out
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest black clover news and
updates and of course this video will be
talking about the latest developments in
the black lore stories so manga spoilers
will follow please proceed with caution
you have been warned so to put it as
simply as possible
hasta Santa magic has the ability to
nullify other forms of magic in fact it
is so effective that anyone who tries to
use anti magic will instantly have their
own magic nullified so the only person
who is able to use anti magic
effectively is Austin specifically
because he was born without any magical
abilities if he had been born with magic
the 5-leaf grimoire that he uses would
instantly drain Asta's mana and render
him useless ironically asked his biggest
obstacle in life the fact that he was
born without any magic is the reason why
he is the only one capable of
effectively using anti magic later on in
the story we learned that asked us
5-leaf grimoire once belonged to licked
the leader of the elf tribe back when
licked on this grimoire it had only four
leaves not five this has been confusing
to a lot of people and they wonder
whether licked was also able to use anti
magic back when he was the owner of this
grimoire the fact is that licked did not
possess anti magic he possessed sword
magic and secrete confirms that hasta
gained the ability to
use anti-magic because his current
grimoire and licks former grimoire was
imbued with anti magic after it became a
five leaf grimoire and after the demon
became trapped inside the five leaf
grimoire no longer belongs to lift and
lift directly confirms this himself
meaning that once the demon entered the
grimoire and it changed from a four leaf
to a five leaf grimoire it was no longer
the same grimoire and it no longer had
the same owner as the story progresses
we learned that the demon inside of
asters grimoire is actually from another
dimension meaning that aunty magic is
actually an otherworldly power
this is confirmed by the fact that
unlike almost all other magic from this
world Asta's aunty magic actually has an
effect on the devil a major villain in
black clover who is also confirmed to be
from another dimension and who appears
to be the same type of creature as the
demon inside of osdas grimoire because
this grimoire once belonged to licked
hasta is able to summon swords from the
grimoire that he uses in battle and this
includes at one point or another the
demon slayer sword the demon dwellers
sword and the demon destroyer sword but
unlike Licht
hasta is able to infuse these swords
with anti magic and use them in various
ways both offensively and defensively
for example the demon slayer sword can
cut the magic of others with its edges
or deflect the spells of others if hasta
hits them with the flat end of the sword
this sword can also remove spells and
enchantments from other people if asta
touches the person with the sword
however anti magic is only capable of
nullifying other forms of magic it does
not nullify physical attacks
so if hasta is in a fight that doesn't
involve any magic his sword will become
just a large blunt object the demon
dwellers sword has the ability to absorb
the magic of others and then unleash the
stored magic back at the opponent the
sword absorbs all magic in its immediate
area and this includes the user's magic
as well and this sword is also very
heavy physically under these
circumstances
hasta is the ideal user for this sword
because he doesn't have any magic that
the sword can take from him meaning that
he can use the sword
any repercussions for himself and
because hasta was born without magic he
spent most of his life training to make
himself physically stronger which is
what allows him to handle such a heavy
sword asta can use the diamond dweller
sword to drain the magic of his
opponents and then use it against them
and we also have the demon destroyer
sword which on top of being able to
nullify magic and cut through spells can
also remove the effects of magic spells
from other people but this sword is so
powerful that it can even undo
reincarnation magic on contact by
hitting someone who has been affected by
reincarnation magic and possessed by a
mouth this sword can actually banish the
elf on top of these sword related
abilities auste can also use his anti
magic and other creative ways such as
allowing anti magic to flow through his
body and allowing that dark energy to
propel him through the air or towards an
opponent while nullifying all the magic
around him such as when he uses the move
black hurricane or the black ass to form
the black asked a form automatically
targets strong magic and rushes to
nullify it and the better hasta gets in
controlling his movements while in this
form the stronger he becomes against
opponents with large reserves of mana in
certain situations it is possible to
combine hasta Santa magic with magic
abilities such as you knows wind magic
but this requires a very specific set of
circumstances and a large amount of
skill and teamwork overall in the world
of black Clover where magic is extremely
important in everyday life an ability
like anti magic is really opie
especially when used in an effective way
nevertheless hasta Santa magic won't
help him against strong physical attacks
so that is one of his weaknesses asta
tries to make up for this weakness by
training his body and improving his own
physical strength all of these aspects
of Asta's anti magic are pretty well
established but there are some lingering
mysteries that make me extremely curious
about the true nature of the 5-leaf
grimoire for one thing we recently
learned that hasta Santa magic is
otherworldly magic because the demon
inside Asta's grimoire is from another
dimension for another in Chapter 200 of
the manga we witnessed hasta Santa magic
working in a way that is very different
from how it normally seems to work in
Chapter 200
hasta Santa magic somehow allows him to
enter poetry's mind ie
his innermost consciousness after pachi
became a dark elf and basically went
berserk as asta touches pachi with the
demon destroyer sword in an attempt to
bring him out of the Dark Elf form head
back to normal he suddenly gains access
to Patras mind including his memories
and emotions the sword which had used
anti magic to absorb some of Patras
magic was somehow also transmitting
Patras memories to ask them if we had
just learned that the demon destroyer
sword allows asta to see the memories of
the person he touches with it that in
itself would be pretty cool it is an
impressive new ability that can prove to
be very useful but that is not all after
gaining access to Potteries memories
hasta is somehow able to enter the
innermost crevices of Patras mind and he
is able to directly communicate with
Patri on the inside
asta is able to confront poetry and
convince him to snap out of it which
leads Patri to come out of the dark elf
form and return to his normal form
although he retains some characteristics
and abilities of the dark elf for I feel
like a lot of people just kind of
glossed over this because this whole arc
has been so intense and so much has been
happening but the events of chapter 200
are incredibly important and they cannot
be overlooked
hasta Santa magic does not only nullify
magic it also allows us to access the
memories and innermost thoughts of
others and it even allows him to enter
the mind of another person and actively
communicate with that person on the
inside we know that the demon who is
trapped inside of osdas grimoire is from
another dimension and we know that
demons are able to possess objects and
people Asta's demon is currently
possessing the 5-leaf grimoire and the
devil has shown himself to be capable of
possessing both humans and elves we have
seen in the past that the demon inside
of the 5-leaf grimoire is able to
communicate with hasta inside his mind
but up until this point we didn't know
that the demon could also allow hasta to
infiltrate the mind of someone else read
their memories and communicate with them
directly inside their own minds this is
far more than just a small passing
detail.this has the ability to change
the game in black clover if asta can
harness this power in the future he can
use it to his advantage in many battles
since it essentially amounts to being
able to read your enemy's mind or at
least certain aspects of their mind
what's more if we know that demons can
possess objects and people and the demon
inside of us as grimoire can allow us
that to enter the minds of people
through his anti magic then it is
possible that asta could eventually
learn to effectively possess and control
his rivals from the inside
we know that hasta is a good guy in that
he isn't the type of person to abuse
this power but it is still fascinating
to consider all of the possibilities
that come with the ability to read and
even enter the mind of your enemies
during his fight with la grosse hasta
engages in an internal battle with the
demon inside his grimoire the demon
offers to defeat la de ros for hasta if
only hasta would allow the demon to take
control of his body the demon says that
he has been waiting for a chance to take
possession of a physical body and that
he intends to take Austin's however
never giving up his Austin's magic and
he manages to increase his power without
giving in to the demons offered to take
his body and so the demon remains inside
the grimoire although the demon's anti
magic continues to help hasta especially
during the recent battle against the
devil I wonder what would happen if a
star really tried to take over the body
and mind of someone else perhaps an
opponent who is too powerful to defeat
in a conventional way and who can only
be stopped by taking him over from the
inside would that person be possessed by
hasta or by the demon if fast as the one
who possesses this person then would the
demon get a chance to take over Austin's
body while hasta is busy trying to
possess someone else could that lead to
a demon possessed hasta becoming the
next major villain in black clover there
are still so many questions about the
demons and about Austin's demon in
particular more importantly now that we
know that anti magic comes from another
dimension and now that we've seen hasta
use anti magic to enter poetry's mind
and directly communicate with Patras
innermost consciousness i think that the
real secret of hasta Santa
magic is that up to this point we have
only been scratching the surface of anti
Magic's true potential I think that a
lot more information will soon be
revealed about Austin's demon and about
anti magic and these revelations will
have a major impact on the story with
the introduction of alternate dimensions
and overpowered creatures like the devil
hasta z-- otherworldly anti magic which
actually has an effect on the devil will
become increasingly more important and
that means that we will finally learn
more about it personally I'm extremely
curious and excited to see the full
extent of Ava's anti magic and the true
origins of the demon inside osdas
grimoire and it is possible that some of
the new things that we learn will pose
serious challenges for hasta afterall we
still don't know what exactly the demon
inside of austin's grimoire is really up
to and if his intentions are sinister
the fact that we still don't know a lot
about anti magic can be used to the
demon's advantage in the future I
predict that more twists and turns that
are directly related to Austin's
grimoire and anti magic are coming soon
and I can't wait to see what will happen
next in the story of black clover let me
know what you guys think what are the
origins and the true intentions of
austin's demon what is the full
potential of Asta's anti magic are there
any additional powers and abilities
related to anti magic that you think
will be revealed in the future let me
know down in the comments I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to stay up
to date on all the latest black over
news and updates you can follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar a
huge thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our work I
want to give a special thank you to our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson and Kings ljus and another
huge thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ace
Ingrid ah Maddy Mac and Makoto
and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison a disciple
of Lord to ego himself if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
uproar patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]